et la levée progressive du déconfinement
donc débuté mais avec des restrictions à
paris on l'aura compris situés en zone
rouge et avec une forte densité
population elle port du masque
transports en commun réouverture des
écoles distanciation social gestes
barrières et est la capitale est elle
prête à ceux des conflits nés c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes avec
aurélien véron candidat à la mairie de
paris centre pour rachida dati bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous à aurélien véron
à ses côtés rémi branco ex chef de
cabinet du ministère de l'agriculteur de
culture pardon elle soutient lui daniel
go merci à vous d'être avec nous aux
premières questions pour vous aurélien
véron de manière globale on rentrera
dans le détail après selon vous anne
hidalgo est elle suffisamment anticipé
ces crises et surtout le le
déconfinement le sentiment que j'ai
après ces deux mois confinement c'est
que elle improvise depuis quinze jours
le déconfinement en ayant attendu
pendant ces deux mois que quelque chose
se passe au niveau de l'état que les
autorités du délivre un message est
aujourd'hui le sec la séquence des
masques ce matin vous savez ces fameux
masque qui sont arrivés en rouleaux de
ml qui sont des masques certainement
utile pour des personnes les journées
qui sont très mal pratique et pas adapté
aux personnes âgées s'est reconnue par
axel l'entreprise française qui les a
fabriquées
c'est un amateurisme d'improvisation
donc nous sortons de deux mois de
confinement qui a pendant lesquelles la
mairie paris a été même continuer
personne n'a vu d'avion les rues
personne n'avait de programmes
personnages ou de masques personnage une
organisation et aujourd'hui elle nous
sort des mesures qui sont inactifs soit
encore des échecs patents le coût des
masques est flagrant mais dans tous les
domaines la mobilité la fermeture de la
rue de rivoli dans son antre de bail
auxquelles je suis confronté alors
aujourd'hui j'ai pas beaucoup de
circulation parce que les gens
reprennent le travail très doucement ça
paralyse les quatre à blinis mans et ça
reporte sur les arrondissements voisins
tous les bouchons d
parisien des personnes de banlieue qui
viennent en voiture par nécessité donc
tout ça c'est très désorganisée et la
confusion malheureusement cette crise
s'ajoute à celle de l'état les parisiens
sont très démuni rennais branco un
jugement un diagnostic plutôt sévère
votre réaction
alors je partage une partie du
diagnostic à savoir qu'effectivement
l'état et le gouvernement en particulier
n'ont pas été à la hauteur des attentes
que pouvaient avoir les habitants en
france et à paris en particulier
on aurait dû prendre des mesures bien
plus tôt pour prévoir ce déconfinement
la maire de paris à fait les
propositions déjà dès le début du mois
d'avril pour essayer d'imaginer un
déconfinement puisque à l'heure où elle
l'a fait personne ne donner des pistes
pour en sortir
donc contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
je pense vraiment que la mairie de paris
est exemplaire et a pris la place dans
quelque sorte de l'état qu'ensuite tout
ne soit pas parfait à 100 % c'est vrai
je parlais des masques c'est vrai qu'à
une minorité de masques qui a été
adressée et qui aujourd'hui ne
correspond pas au confort que
souhaiterait notamment des personnes
âgées c'est vrai en revanche ces masques
il fonctionne la mokrane majorité des
masses qui sont distribués aujourd'hui
au parisien
il faut les encourager à aller sur
paris.fr en faire la demande
ils sont très efficaces et ils sont très
pratiques moi je mets en garde
le type de critiques qu'on a entendu de
la part de madame dati visant à dire que
des masques ne fonctionnerait pas il
faudrait pas que ce soit un message qui
pousserait les parisiens ne pas en faire
la demande
là ce serait très grave par ailleurs
c'est un manque de respect aussi pour
une belle française
là j'ai eu tout ce qui a trait aux
personnes âgées qui est vrai vous le
reconnaissez oui par ailleurs un
insolent masques par personne est ce
bien suffisant sachant également là
c'est peut-être pour vous olivier
verront que voilà quand on interroge un
petit peu les parisiens à droite à
gauche selon les arrondissements on
apprend dans le set sienne
oui ou rachida dati et la mer et bien
les masques sont distribués à profusion
évidemment elle est en campagne
électorale aussi donc la politique
peut-être joue un rôle que dans certains
arrondissements il faut faire sa petite
demande sur internet c'est on reçoit un
seul masque en tout et pourtant ou
sachant qu'on doit elle changer tous les
4 heures à ce que c'est normal c'est
deux poids deux mesures la question des
masses qui s'allonge de logistique et là
nous revenions sur le fait que l'état a
été totalement à côté de la réalité
pendant au moins le mois qui a séparé le
début du confinement à aujourd'hui
et donc il ya un retard flagrant lorsque
valérie pécresse en ile de france comme
en 2011 masque pour paris et que les
livres et puis je n'ai maire
d'arrondissement s'organise on voit bien
quelques séquences logistique qui est
anticipé par des mères le rôle des
mairies c'est un rôle de logistique et
d'accompagnement quant à la sécurité de
la mobilité de la propreté qui est un
gros mois dans la capitale
mais déjà la logistique est un vrai
métier est une vraie un vrai enjeu
municipalité à deux collectivités
territoriales anne hidalgo s'est
réveillée très bas alors est ce qu'elle
est apparue est libre et les masques fin
avril comme elle l'avait promis ou bon
là on est son bar à pinailler sur les
dates c'est compliqué que lui-même pas
la pierre parce qu'encore une fois tous
les échelons de l'état en faillite
mais quand vous riegler m geoffroy
boulard qui sont autant en campagne que
hidalgo je vous signale tout le monde
est en campagne
il s'agit pas d'une campagne il s'agit
d'une épidémie une pandémie mondiale
le rôle d'un maire c'est d'abord
d'anticiper et de prévoir et d'organiser
l'un je constate que les maires
notamment à la chine at il été élu au
premier tour
organise la logistique pid au prétexte
notamment des tests mais les a fait les
tests l'auto roule à rossi on attend
daminato des tests massive dans les
arrondissements pour les personnels
soignants pour les particuliers pas dans
les laboratoires dans la rue accessible
et on se rend compte que tout ça alors
le plan publié dans la presse par anne
hidalgo en avril à fin avril est arrivé
tardivement de bonnes idées
je reconnais c'était du copier-coller
parce que les allemands font c'est
plutôt une photo un plan qui est
intéressant
mais où sont les actes le mobilier
urbain n'a jamais été nettoyée dans
l'arrondissement premier et le deuxième
je n'ai pas vu de nettoyage pendant deux
mois les détritus s'accumulent et les
sdf ont ressoudé sanisettes il ya quinze
jours où les sdr qui n'avaient plus
accès au bar qui était fermé et plus
accès aux salles dizaines de co qui est
également à l'abandon complet
on a vu des sanisettes rempli de
seringue de capote d'un bordel
innommable
les fds n'ont reçu leurs sanitaires
mobiles que ya quinze jours tout ça est
très improvisés on aurait aimé un
général d'armée à l'amérique paris on a
un lieutenant votre réponse régulière
branco non c'est malheureusement bon je
suis un peu affligé par ce genre de
critiques de désolé de le dire mais
quand on parle des sdf
il a fallu s'organiser en premier lieu
pour leur trouver des logements pour
leur trouver des lieux d'accueil c'est
ce qui a été fait dans des gymnases
il a fallu aussi par la défaillance de
l'état compensé le manque des cantines
la fermeture des cantines pour
énormément de familles ces trente mille
familles populaires parisienne qui ont
eu grâce à la mairie de paris
les aides financières pour pouvoir
donner à manger à leurs enfants l'état
l'a promis on attend toujours la date le
montant de ces aides
la mairie de paris l'a proposé à une
dalle gaulle a fait ces familles là
aujourd'hui
elles ont des aides directes pour
pouvoir manger ce qu'ils étaient il ya
un mois un des principaux une des
principales craintes des pouvoirs
publics à savoir que une crise sociale
voire une crise alimentaire allait
toucher de nombreuses familles modestes
choix qu'il faut vraiment sûr c'est être
très humble tout ne peut pas être
parfait
tout ne peut pas être anticipé en une
dans une crise on le sait sans précédent
les municipalités font ce qu'elles
peuvent s'agissant des sdf je trouve
pour le coup que la polémique est mal
choisi puisque vraiment ces populations
la ruhr était à risque
les maraudes ont pas pu se faire
normalement pendant de nombreux jours
voire semaines est vraiment la mairie de
paris a fait tout ce qu'elle pouvait
pour accueillir au mieux ces populations
et aider celles qui pouvait plus nourrir
nos enfants faute de cantine alors l'une
des grandes actualités du jour c'est
évidemment la reprise des écoles seuls
15% des écoliers parisiens font leur
rentrée le 14 mai selon anne hidalgo
c'était une rentrée trop précoce selon
vous aurélien
au contraire on a eu raison quel est
votre votre réaction sur cette reprise
de l'école à paris aujourd'hui ou
septembre vers l'ue sera toujours là on
tient à un moment il faut reprendre
fortement doucement il faut expérimenter
ne manquent pas aujourd'hui sont un peu
dans la confusion à ce c'est pas simple
aucune
encore une fois entre alors ça dépend si
on part du primaire du secondaire mais
l'organisation de la rentrée était quand
même chaotique alors là je jette la
pierre à personne parce que et de
conneries des académies comme du point
de vue d'amérique paris c'est des sujets
lourds il faut de la concertation des
enseignants des directeurs d'école non
c'est très compliqué il fallait
reprendre l'école c'est une bonne chose
les enfants ont besoin de reprendre le
fil de l'enseignement de l'éveil de mort
sociale et de loin de l'apprentissage
des fondamentaux
il fallait pas attendre parce qu'une
bonne chose de commencer même réaction
rien verrons il fallait reprendre
l'école c'était important
alors oui il fallait reprendre l'école
et en même temps là aussi je partage
totalement ce qui a été dit par monsieur
viron on pouvait pas de faire du jour au
lendemain une rentrée complète avec 100%
des élèves on pouvait pas non plus dire
qu'on attendait septembre il fallait que
cette rentrée commence à se faire et va
se faire progressivement avec une
adaptation la fois des personnels
municipaux des enseignants eux mêmes
et puis là aussi c'est quand même
compliqué pour des parents qui sont mis
devant une responsabilité qui est lourde
avec cette scolarisation sur la base du
volontariat
est-ce que je mets en danger mes enfants
les amenant à l'école est ce que voilà
est-ce que pour l'heure bien je dois les
amener ou pas à l'école bon c'est des
sujets qui sont lourds et je crois que
ça peut ne se remettre en place vraiment
que progressivement
jour après jour semaine après semaine
c'est qu'un début à la fois pour les
crèches les écoles et les collégiens
espérons que rapidement tout le monde
prenne ses marques
aurélien véron jeantet d'ajouter qu'on
fait tout à l'heure les listes
prioritaires est ce que c'est une bonne
chose selon vous vous comprenez que ça
soit aussi compliqué à vivre pour
certains parents certains peuvent mettre
leurs enfants d'autres noms pour voilà
des raisons de métier
notamment la une proposition qui a été
faite par les théâtres de la ville de
paris théâtre du privé notamment c'était
de mettre à disposition leurs salles qui
sont inutilisables pour que les classes
qui sont cotisés effectif puis se
disperser dans des espaces différents
avec des de gestion sanitaire impeccable
combat que les enfants soient au mieux
des grands espaces de théâtre pourrait
être ma disposition moyenne -
financement qui va toutes façons de voir
venir
si nous voulons la survie devaient être
privés mais donc y est né il ya des
propositions d'acteurs de la vie de
paris privé qui sont prêts à suppléer le
nombre d'espacés des écoles donc il faut
que très rapidement alors la montée en
charge les progrès si parce qu'on teste
on expérimente on rassure et les
enseignants prennent leurs repères ils
sont quand même très rapidement que tous
les élèves puissent aller à l'école
parce que l'inégalité qui naîtrait
effectivement d'un d'un décrochage de
ceux qui n'ont pas que ça décolle par
rapport à ce qui serait privilégiée sera
très vite intenable et je crois qu'il
est de la devoir de la mairie de paris
au moins dans primaire de n'assurer que
le maximum d'élèves très vite et accès à
l'école par souci d'égalité
encore une fois les espaces existe il ya
des acteurs qui proposent leur aide
essayons de coordonnées et c'est là que
je pense qu'il faut un général d'armée
quelqu'un qui soit prêt à vendre très
vite dans l'action tous ces acteurs pour
s'organiser
je pense que ce serait de commencer bien
avant les propositions sont apparus b à
brides et hélas aujourd'hui entre est
leader il n'est jamais trop tard il faut
s'organiser mais encore une fois la
mairie n'est pas seul il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs privés qui sont prêts à aider
qu'ils ont plein d'idées qui ont besoin
d aide
mais on échange des aides seront alors
que l'état où la ville de paris va leur
apporter
ils sont prêts à inventer aussi leur
aide logistique passoire pratique des
espaces pour les écoles un dernier thème
messieurs qui très lol débat en tout cas
en train il algoé et le ministre de la
santé
rémi branco anne hidalgo qui dit
l'ouverture des portes est une question
de santé publique
alors on a vu des images vous allez nous
donner leur avis votre avis là dessus
sur le canal saint martin des français
des jeunes français qui se sont
rassemblés effectivement se demandent où
ils peuvent se rassembler ouverture des
parcours imagine que vous êtes pour
comme anne hidalgo
rémi branco moi je suis évidemment pour
à la fois en tant que parisien
parce que quand on est confiné par deux
mois dans un appartement petit a
fortiori quand on est une famille
nombreuse
le fait d'avoir accès les espaces se
soit déjà l'air libre mais en plus des
espaces où on peut respirer comme les
parcs
c'est quelque chose d'important mais
aussi c'est important pour limiter la
programme la propagation du virus
ce qu'on a vu sur le canal saint martin
c'est la résultante directe du manque
des espaces verts du manque d'espacé où
on peut marcher s'aérer sans être sur un
trottoir de boulevard ou d'un venu à
faire respirer les pots d'échappement à
ses enfants donc je pense justement
qu'en voyant ces images du canal saint
martin le ministre de la santé aurait dû
en déduire qu'il fallait augmenter le
nombre d' espaces disponibles pour les
parisiens en revanche ça doit évidemment
se faire d'un dialogue avec la
préfecture
mais dans le sérieux et la rigueur qu'on
doit pas dire aux habitants de paris
allez-y elle dans les parcs aller
pique-niquer réunissez-vous alesi à 20 à
30 morts il faudra des règles très
strictes en contrôle policier qui soit
très ferme
oui les parisiens doit avoir accès au
parc de la ville de paris mais dans des
conditions les plus strictes pour qu'on
n'ait pas de propagation du virus
comme on a pu le voir sur canal
saint-martin cas manifestement c'est non
pour olivier ferrand pour l'instant
aurélien véron sur ce point alors sur ce
point là je vais rejoindre la position
du clan hidalgo je crois aussi et je les
exprime et qu'il faut absolument ouvrir
des pâtes jardin j'aurais aimé qualité
des eaux des faons d'ouverture des
marchés de rue parce qu'encore une fois
toutes les activités en extérieur sont
beaucoup moins dangereux que les
activités en intérieur
aller dans un magasin fermé c'est plus
dangereux que jamais les courses dans un
magasin ouvert et notamment les marchés
de rue notamment alors aujourd'hui avec
des pâtes oui faut les ouvrir et du mal
à comprendre qu'un ministre qui a
cafouillé dans sa politique de santé
depuis deux mois impose à la ville de
bari ces conditions alors que la ligue
de paris est en train de remettre en
activité les agents de la ville de paris
met du gène et même si je dis non
certaine confusion dans la gestion de
en filmant et du poste continent je
pense qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est
prêt on a besoin d'eux c'est pas parce
que les rues sont insuffisants on est la
ville la plus dense d'europe
nous avons un ami habitants au kilomètre
carré tous les jours de la banlieue
viennent des travailleurs qui viennent
presque augmenté de 20 à 30%
cette densité peut-être moins
aujourd'hui parce que le travail avait
progressivement mais ça veut dire qu'on
est plus de 22 23 25 mille habitants au
kilomètre carré d'honneur et les
reverrons eni banques ont des zones et
on arrive à les à l'issue de ce débat
merci à vous d'avoir été en direct sur
rfo